avant versailles il y avait saint
germain en laye résidences royales ce
château aura hébergé françois 1er henri
de henri iv ou encore louis xiii mais en
16 182 le départ de louis xiv mettra fin
à son aménagement
les plans du grand architecte le nôtre
resteront inachevé
ce n'est que trois cent cinquante ans
plus tard que le grand bassin monumental
pourra finalement voir le jour au coeur
du domaine en 2022 il prendra place ici
dans les jardins à la française vous
avez toujours un élément aquatique
c'est le grand canal à versailles ce
sont des bassins donc qu'il existait
vraiment ou non ces jardins ont été
conçus pour que ce grand bassin il
existe ce chantier de plus de quatre
millions et demi d'euros financés par la
ville le département l'état mais aussi
grâce à des partenaires privés et des
dons de particuliers à d'ores et déjà
débuté et s'il a été rendue possible
c'est uniquement grâce à d'autres
travaux à proximité
ceux du tram 13 en créant une
correspondance avec le rer a un look à
la fontainerie souterrain pourra être
installé reconstituer ce grand bassin
c'est elle que par terminer l'oeuvre de
l'autre et c'est une c'est techniquement
assez compliqué parce que comment se
situe au dessus des voûtes du des lignes
de rer et de la gare du rer est bien
il faut en fait faire reposer ce grand
bassin qui sera un bassin de grandes
dimensions 50 m de diamètre avec un jet
d'eau de 20 mètres de haut sur une une
centaine de micropieux et l'inauguration
du site pourrait être l'occasion d'un
grand moment de célébration lors des
prochaines journées du patrimoine